un show de drag queen como este estará
prohibido a los menores de edad este
tipo de manifestaciones no podrán
empezar antes de las 10 de la noche son
algunas de las consecuencias de la
llamada ley anti el fbi oficialmente
dirigida a combatir la pedofilia
el texto entró en vigor este miércoles
en hungría
estoy bastante intranquilo a la demencia
no creo que debamos ser confundidos con
pedófilos en la misa de ayer y no creo
que algo así debe ocurrir en pleno siglo
21 adoptada el 15 de junio en el
parlamento húngaro la ley prohíbe
textualmente poner a disposición de los
menores contenidos que muestren o
fomenten la sexualidad el cambio de
género o la homosexualidad por ejemplo
ya no estará permitida la publicidad que
muestre a dos hombres o dos mujeres
besándose algunas cadenas de televisión
afirmaron que no podrán difundir
películas donde haya relaciones
homosexuales la legislación también
ataca los cursos de educación sexual que
sólo podrán ser impartidos por
organizaciones
ante las autoridades en un principio la
ley tenía como objetivo endurecer las
penas a las personas condenadas por
pedofilia sin embargo pocos días antes
del voto final el partido fidesz del
presidente viktor orbán añadió enmiendas
relacionadas con los derechos lgbt de
cara a las elecciones legislativas
orbán se ha radicalizado en materia de
política social especialmente contra las
personas migrantes y lg vettel por
ejemplo en diciembre de 2020 modificó la
constitución para prohibir que las
parejas homosexuales puedan adoptar